de gira este es un operativo sin
precedentes en la historia peruana nunca
la justicia había ingresado a la sede
del poder ejecutivo para detener una
persona es esto legal porque se da
precisamente durante el accidentado
gobierno de castillo
si lo que ocurre es que en el presidente
castillo está rodeado de un entorno que
incluye familiares suyos que están
sospechados de haber realizado actos de
corrupción y la la tesis de la fiscalía
es que el mismo sería la cabeza de esa
organización la cuestión con el
presidente es particular porque él solo
puede ser acusado y llevado proceso
penal judicial por cuatro delitos
traición a la patria cerrar el congreso
no convocar elecciones o impedir la
reunión de los organismos electorales
por cualquier otro delito como los que
los que son el objeto de las acusaciones
contra sus allegados y también
familiares él solo puede ser procesado
penalmente al terminar su mandato es
decir el 28 de julio de 2026
sin embargo
puede realizarse un proceso
parlamentario de la institución y eso
cuando cliente se le encuentre incurso
en una infracción constitucional es este
acceso parlamentario no es para
habilitar el procesamiento penal sino
para que el congreso decida absorberlo o
condenarlo por la acusación que se
formula en su contra de haber infringido
algún artículo de la constitución por
ejemplo si el presidente del perú
oculta a un prófugo a un allegado
familiar prófugo él estaría infringiendo
el artículo 118 de la constitución pero
que obliga al presidente a cumplir y
hacer cumplir las resoluciones
judiciales y un prófugo es un sujeto que
está con orden de captura judicial en
este caso el presidente estaría incurso
en una infracción constitucional y
podría ser acusado y sancionado por el
congreso con la destitución una vez
destituido ya podría ser procesado por
cualquiera de los delitos que se le
imputan en este momento a sus allegados
y a él se le está investigando también
ahora esta serie de renuncias de
funcionarios y personas cercanas al
castillo hoy la de su abogado que tanto
debilitan al mandatario
y lo debilitan políticamente por la
reacción que puede haber en la gente la
reacción de desconfianza e inseguridad
respecto de la estabilidad del país pero
los caminos hacia su procesamiento penal
van por las dos rutas que acaba de
mencionar el primero un proceso un
juicio político que incluyen su
destitución no por los delitos sino por
alguna infracción constitucional y una
vez destituido se les podrá procesar
penalmente y en el poder judicial se
verá si es culpable o inocente
ahora toda esta luego de toda esta serie
de escándalos que han rodeado el
mandatario viene una gran pregunta y es
sí pedro castillo va a terminar el
mandato que cree usted
lo que ocurre es que voluntariamente
podría renunciar pero si renuncia pierde
la protección del artículo 117 de la
constitución y podría ser inmediatamente
profesor penalmente así que es difícil
que renuncie el único camino que tiene
que existe para que no te en el auto el
long street es que el congreso pone en
marcha este proceso llamado juicio
político pero aparentemente el congreso
no quiere hacerlo porque teme que si
destituye al castillo luego
pierde el cargo su vicepresidenta
detalles que resumimos partido y la
presidenta del congreso convoque
elecciones parlamentarias y
presidenciales con lo cual los
conferencias pierden el cargo entonces
casi podría decirse que están cuidando a
su puesto
y por eso no emplea el juicio político
contra castillo